[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja das turbulente
und anstrengende jahr 2020 liegt hinter
uns
zum glück die abwahl von donald trump
die proteste der schwarzen bevölkerung
die brände im flüchtlingslager moria und
in australien
die explosion in beirut zahlreiche
terroranschläge und natürlich die alles
überlagernde pandemie heute fragen will
wir welche lehren wir aus diesen
katastrophen jahr ziehen können ja
ziehen müssen damit die nächsten jahre
und jahrzehnte etwas angenehmer werden
ein gast ist der in wien lebende
historiker philosoph und bestseller
autor philipp blom herzlich willkommen
danke sehr
ja herr blum herr wie würden sie denn
dieses historische jahr 2020
zusammenfassten für die geschichtsbücher
von morgen sozusagen für die gesehen
wissen sie das ist immer so schwierig
weil wir sind noch mittendrin
und es ist ganz seltsam wie dinge
erinnert werden das kann man jetzt
eigentlich noch nicht sagen zum beispiel
die spanische grippe wo 50.000 menschen
wahrscheinlich oder vielleicht sogar 150
millionen oder 100 millionen menschen
umgekommen sind
vor genau 100 jahren hat kaum spuren in
der erinnerung hinterlassen weil der
erste weltkrieg gerade vorher passiert
war und so viel wichtiger war
wir kommen aber jetzt nach seiner langen
zeit zumindest in westeuropa von frieden
und wohlstand und das ist sozusagen das
erste schlechte ding was vielen menschen
passiert ist diese pandemie
es ist das erste mal dass der staat zu
stark in das leben zu von menschen
zurückgekehrt ist als instanz die sagt
du darfst dies und du darfst das nicht
aber wir sind auch da zu helfen
also und es ist das erste ja dass die
routine unterbrochen wurde und für mich
ist das glaube ich dass was vielleicht
am wichtigsten gewesen sein wird an
diesem jahr alle menschen die vorher
diesen wahnsinnigen globalen hyper
kapitalismus kritisiert haben haben zu
hören bekommen ja das ist zwar
schrecklich was mit den regenwäldern
passiert ist es alles sehr traurig aber
wir können den globalen kapitalismus
nicht anhalt
das geht nicht das brauchen wir auch
aber es ist auch einfach unmöglich
und dann ist es passiert innerhalb von
wenigen tagen ist dieses system nicht
zum stillstand gebracht worden aber doch
radikal verlangsamt worden
wir haben gelernt dass wir als
gesellschaften entscheidungen treffen
können und dass wir dass es auch anders
geht dass wir nicht in einer betonwanne
sitze und einfach in eine richtung
rutschen müssen
ich glaube das wird uns übrig bleiben
ich habe einen satz bei ihm gelesen was
ich schreiben wir menschen lernen aus
der geschichte wir reagieren nur auf
traumata ist die pandemie vielleicht so
ein traumata zum trauma das werden wir
sehen
leider ist diese pandemie wahrscheinlich
nicht die einzige die wir erleben werden
und es ist nicht die einzige sehr
schwere situation die unsere
gesellschaften in den nächsten
jahrzehnten und jahren erleben werden
insofern ob diese epidemie an sich so
heraus steht das kann eigentlich erst
die zukunft zeigen
aber die idee mit den traumata nein wir
haben nicht die lehren aus dem
dreißigjährigen krieg sind verloren
die lehren aus dem zweiten weltkrieg die
werden gerade verloren denn wir wir
reagieren auf erfahrungen wie auch
individuen oder familien reagieren
werden eine familie ein massives trauma
erlebt ein mensch stirbt ein kind stirbt
so etwas dann kann das die familie zwei
bis drei generationen begleiten so als
schatten und menschen richten ihr
handeln auch danach so etwas wie zu
vermeiden dass so etwas passiert sie
sind dann besonders vorsichtig oder sie
machen etwas anderes
wir sehen das in europa nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg die prioritäten waren auf
allen auf einmal internationale
zusammenarbeit soziale umverteilung
friedenssicherung all diese dinge mit
denen wir in europa auf gefahr
menschenrechte menschenrechte und das
war natürlich auch ein
vermeidungsverhalten nach dem was im
zweiten weltkrieg passiert war
wir erleben jetzt und zwar besonders bei
jüngeren menschen dass die sagen ja ich
weiß nicht ob das so wichtig ist ich
weiß nicht ob der demokratie jemand die
beste staatsform ist eigentlich ist doch
ein starker mann
auch ein attraktives mittel also dass
diese dass diese politischen reflexe die
meine mutter war im krieg geflohen
ich bin mit diesen geschichten noch
aufgewachsen das war für mich noch
indirekt lebende geschichte
wenn ich kinder hätte wäre das für die
geschichten von ihrer großmutter
das ist etwas völlig anderes und ich
glaube das ist insofern wie wir auf
dieses sicherlich dieses trauma
reagieren
ich hoffe wir regieren klug drauf ich
hoffe wir reagieren darauf und ich hoffe
wir reagieren klug brauchen das heißt
zum ersten mal zuerst mal zu sehen
diese pandemie ist nicht ein
einzigartiges ereignis sondern sie ist
eine konsequenz des selben phänomens wie
die klimakatastrophe nämlich die
tatsache dass wir immer tiefer in die
natur eingreifen als gesellschaften
immer tiefer natürliche zusammenhänge
eingreifen immer stärker natürliche
systeme verändern und das feld auf uns
zurück einfach weil diese systeme jetzt
anders funktionieren wir werden mehr zu
und viren abbekommen weil wir es so
viele wild märkte gibt und weil wir so
tief in die in die habitat hineingehen
dass wir da viren begegnen die wir den
wir bevor er nicht begegnet sind
das heißt also wenn wir klug daraus
lernen dann würde ich sagen dass kluge
daraus lernen wäre eben nicht das
wiederhochfahren der wirtschaft sondern
zu sagen wir kommen aus einem system was
die welt und vielleicht auch uns enorm
beschädigt hat was auch zweifellos
riesige qualitäten hatte vielleicht ist
dies die möglichkeit dieses system auf
den prüfstand zu stellen und anzusehen
und dinge auch anders zu machen
intelligent damit zukunftsweisend werden
sie haben die natur angesprochen unser
verhältnis zur natur
aber wir selbst wir menschen sind ja
auch natur das zeigt auch die pandemie
da kommt so ein kleiner erreger und
zeigt dass wir verlässliche biologische
wesen sind ist das eine lehre die
beziehen müssen aus dieser pandemie
ich glaube das ist eine ganz wichtige
lehre die auch über die direkte politik
raus weist wir haben uns im westen sehr
stark konstruiert durch die
trennung zwischen natur und kultur aber
besonders zwischen dem mensch und der
rest der natur wir glauben eigentlich
instinktiv wir stehen über der natur wir
sind etwas anderes wir sind schon etwas
unangenehm berührt wenn wir uns als
zeuge wenn wir als säugetiere
angesprochen werden oder als primaten
das ist irgendwie das gehört nicht dazu
das ist wir sehen uns als etwas
andererseits etwas draußen steht und das
ist eine tradition die eigentlich aus
der bibel kommt dieser exzeptionell
ismus und das heißt auch diese dieses
verhältnis von natur das reine
extrahieren dass wir nehmen uns raus was
wir wollen und das ist eigentlich und
dann finden wir sie vielleicht schön im
romantischen sinne dann finden wir die
alpen erhaben oder so ist aber wir haben
eigentlich kein tieferes kein
instinktives verhältnis zur natur und
das ist ganz seltsam dass die
wissenschaft uns immer mehr nicht nur
zeigt dass unser ganzes begreifen des
kosmos eigentlich nur durch unsere
revolutionäre also durch unsere sinne
bestimmt ist die tatsache dass wir einen
winzigen ausschnitt eines erfahrbaren
sehen und wir glauben aha das ist die
welt und die welt ist offensichtlich für
uns gemacht und sonst wäre das hier
alles nicht da aber dieser mensch als
ein freies vernünftiges autarkes nach
außen abgeschlossenes wesen
diese vision wird im moment von der
wissenschaft völlig zerstört wir wissen
dass wir viel mehr nicht menschliche
zellen in und an uns haben als
menschliche zellen vielmehr nicht
menschliche dna wir wissen dass unsere
eigene dna zum teil aus wieren kommt wir
lernen dass dieses micro biomaterialien
und bazillen die in uns sind nicht nur
unsere verdauung helfen sondern dass wir
unsere intelligenz mitbestimmen unsere
gestimmtheit mitbestimmen dass sie
mitbestimmen ob wir allergiker sind oder
ob wir autistisch werden ob wir
parkinson oder alzheimer haben dieses
diese unbekannte kontinent in uns von
dem die wissenschaft oder sicherlich die
medizin vor 30 jahren noch nicht
gesprochen hat da gab es so eine
darmflora
aber dass dieses mikrobiologen tlx ich
uns völlig konstituiert in jedem unserer
aspekte dass die epigenetik also die
tatsache dass traumata und erfahrung
tatsächlich die expression von genen
verändern können nicht die gene selbst
aber wie sie ausgedrückt werden und das
so erfahrungen und traumata auch
vererbbar sind von einer generation zur
zweiten das heißt natürlich dass die
idee von willensfreiheit und
souveränität des des eigenen selbst auch
zutiefst unterminiert ist wir lernen
dass wir viel mehr teil der natur sind
als wir das eigentlich glaubten und das
ist wahnsinnig spannend das zu sehen
aber das heißt auch dass ein
menschenbild was uns sehr lang getragen
hat jetzt gerade in sich zusammen getan
und sie gehen sogar noch einen schritt
weiter und vergleichen uns menschen mit
den kleinsten lebewesen die hier in
einem glas wein drin senkt mit
sogenannten hefezellen sogar was hat
denn der mensch mit einer hefezellen
gemeinsam die cern daher in diesem fall
werden sie hoffentlich nicht mehr leben
diese hefezellen aber schauen sie es ist
wir haben in diesen wichtigen partner
organismus hefe der macht uns brot der
macht mir der macht war ein da macht
auch viele andere dinge die mich die
sind alles was mit fermentation zu tun
hat und was tut zu einer hefezellen
winziger pilz wenn sie sie in den zug
rieke lösung geben dann denkt sie sich
oral und sie frisst alles was sie vor
sich hat und sie erkennt eine
gigantische bevölkerungsexplosion und
verändert dabei ihre umgebung in dem die
zucker in alkohol umwandelt und
irgendwann erstickt sie an ihren eigenen
ausscheidungen und verhungert das mögen
wir gerne dabei kommt so was raus es ist
aber für mich eine echte intellektuelle
beleidigung mehr zu denken dass nach
plateau und goethe und marie curie und
einen anderen möglichen chinesen holen
kulturen wir nach hunderten von
millionen jahren evolution der hilfe
nichts voraus haben wir fressen alles
was wir vor uns haben und unsere
bevölkerung explodiert und wir sehen
worauf wir zugehen das ist vielleicht
der unterschied zur hilfe
aber wir machen es trotzdem nicht anders
ich habe diese geschichte einmal einer
österreichischen biologin erzählt die
sagte halblaub aber ihre geschichte hat
noch einen zweiten teil
die hefezellen die den großen kollaps
überleben
die verändern ihren stoffwechsel um in
der neuen umgebung zurecht kommen zu
können und das weitergedacht hieße also
die herausforderungen uns ist können wir
uns einmal nicht so verhalten wie uns
die evolution programmiert hat sondern
können wir es schaffen unseren
stoffwechsel zu ändern bevor diese
katastrophe passiert und da muss man
sagen im moment schaut es nicht so rosig
würde das würde heißen unser denken zu
verändern und sein lebensstil zu
verändern und ihrer wirtschaftssystem
ihrem ankauf der entlang der
stoffwechsel unser wirtschaftssystem es
ist man muss kein nobelpreisträger sein
um zu sehen dass man in einer endlichen
system kein endloses wachstum haben kann
und wenn dieses wachstum immer mehr die
natürlichen systeme auf dieses aufbaut
zerrüttet und unterminiert dann
zerrüttet dieses wachstum sich selbst
das ist auch mein problem mit denkern
die sagen schaut euch an
es gibt immer weniger
kindersterblichkeit immer weniger
menschen sterben durch gewalt immer mehr
mädchen gehen auf die schule alles
richtig steven pinker sowie steven
irgendwas us amerikanische psychologe
der alleswisser sein
alles super er hat mich alles wahnsinnig
aber wenn alles das nur möglich ist weil
wir unsere über lebensgrundlage
zerstören dann sind das keine echten
errungenschaften und das ist die das ist
das echte dilemma indem wir im moment
stehen die gesellschaften die wir wollen
die ethischen den die wir verfolgen
wollen die hängen davon ab dass wir eine
robuste wirtschaft haben oder haben das
bis jetzt immer getan aber diese robuste
wirtschaft zerstört uns auch und daraus
einen ausweg zu finden wird nicht nur
gehen über eine idyllische
kreislaufwirtschaft wo alle leute guten
willens sind denn wir leben in sehr
komplizierten gesellschaften und
menschen sind sehr unterschiedlich was
würde das heißen eine
kreislaufwirtschaft
na ja es gibt diese ideen von einer
wirtschaftlich nicht mehr wachsen muss
bzw auch nicht mehr wachsen darf oder
also alles nur
in einem kreislauf verwendet wird und
nicht etwas also nicht dinge
herausgezogen werden um so sehr als ein
spieler ist sozusagen das ultimative
recycling was natürlich das
umweltfreundlichste wäre aber das
problem ist man muss ja auch die guten
ideen möglichst so zur realisierung
bringen dass sie nicht davon abhängen
dass wir dann nach einer ökonomisch wie
ökologisch verschwenderischen demokratie
in einer ökologisch korrekten diktatur
landen
interessant und diese gefahr besteht
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
ach wissen sie ich meine die demokratie
hat immer das große problem sagt
herfried münkler mir mal gesagt er hat
gesagt demokratien sind eigentlich
erfunden worden um entscheidungen zu
verlangsamen damit nicht irgendwann
degenerierte prinz morgens aufsteht und
sich denke ich wir machen jetzt mal
einen kleinen krieg mit dem nachbarland
hat man das alles institutionalisiert
und in komitees eingebettete cetera aber
das verlangsamt natürlich entscheidungen
und das fördert viel mehr kompromisse
und in dieser situation wo wirklich not
herrscht dass wir nicht dass uns die
dynamik des klimas nicht völlig
entgleitet so dass wir nicht mehr drin
leben könnten wir müssten eigentlich
starke maßnahmen getroffen werden und
das ist sehr schwierig in einer
demokratie wenn die meisten wählerinnen
und wähler noch gar nicht sehen dass das
not haben sich ja auch historiker mit
historischen krisen auch beschäftigt und
in einem buch ganz dezidiert mit mit der
kleinen eiszeit wie die heißt das war
eine klimaveränderung im siebzehnten
jahrhundert sagen das klima um zwei grad
es wurde kälter und das hat der radikale
folgen für die wirtschaft und für die
gesellschaft und insofern zeigt das
glaube ich auch dass es eine solche
krisen solche momente der veränderung
immer auch chancen sein können für eine
gesellschaft allerdings ging man da
jeweils unterschiedlich damit um
vielleicht können sie kurz erzählen was
das mit dieser diesem europa 17ten
jahrhunderts gemacht habe also erstmal
zeigt es sehr gut was zwei grad
temperatur änderung bedeutet
denn das ist ja heute die
optimistischste voraussage dass wir
vielleicht mit den temperaturanstieg auf
zwei grad begrenzen können
viele andere forscher sagen der zug
bereits abgefahren aber im 16 07 17
jahrhundert waren es zwei grad 2 grad
durchschnittliche temperatur änderung
heißt nicht nur drei wochen
vegetationsperiode für alle pflanzen
das entscheidet ob was reif wird oder
nicht es heißt zum beispiel auch dass
dies keine hungersnöte es gab riesige
hungers dass die extreme riesig viel
höher sind also wenn heute zwei grad
herrschen
haben sie wenn es heute zwei grad wärmer
wird haben sie in zürich ein sommer der
acht grad wärmer ist als er das bis
jetzt ist und sie können sich davon die
sozialen die politischen konsequenzen
vorstellen auch aber zum beispiel die
architektonischen und städtebaulichen im
17 jahrhundert war es ganz klar erstmal
europa war in agrarischer kontinenten
landbau konnten die meisten leute an
davon gelebt was sie lokal angebaut
haben und das ging sehr lang relativ gut
auch mit einer ziemlichen effizienten
landwirtschaft mit sehr altmodisch und
methoden die sich seit fast 1000 jahren
nicht geändert hatten und dann kam
dieser kälteeinbruch von dem wir immer
noch nicht genau wissen warum er
wirklich passiert ist aber es sehr gut
dokumentiert und auf einmal wurden die
früchte nicht mehr auf einmal verrottet
und das getreide auf dem feld und
natürlichkeit hungersnöte es gab soziale
unruhen
es gab in der stadt statt weil alle
preis in den getreidepreis gekoppelt
waren eine riesige inflation eine
teuerung von 100 prozent im jahr
manchmal und das war natürlich ein
riesiges problem und was man sieht und
was mich interessiert hat ein opfer
dieses klimawandels war die damals
erzählte geschichte der gesellschaft in
diese geschichte war natürlich religiös
gott hat uns die erde gegeben
und gott sorgt dafür dass wir gut leben
können auf dieser erde wenn wir
gottesfürchtig leben und auf einmal tat
gut dass nicht mehr auf einmal ernährte
die menschen nicht mehr und auf einmal
gab es bedürfnis nach neuen und anderen
erklärungen
und es ist ganz spannenden derzeit zu
sehen dass man einen wettbewerb an
alternativen wissens arten sieht also
sie sehen es kommt magier auf und
alchemisten und rosenkreuzer und
mystiker und kabbalisten aber auch die
ersten empirisch forschendem botaniker
oder astronomen oder so etwas also wird
die wissenschaftliche methode war eine
wissens art unter vielen hat sich aber
als die stärkste herausgestellt aber was
wichtig ist ist diese sieht diese lücken
schließen ja ist es aufbrechen einer
situation ich glaube da in dieser
situation sind wir heute wieder dass wir
merken diese diese idee des menschen als
krone der schöpfung die so ein bisschen
zurück geht auf diesen biblischen satz
in genesis 128 macht euch die erde
untertan
die kann nicht mehr für uns
funktionieren weil wir inzwischen weil
wir inzwischen zu mächtig geworden sind
wir sind zu mächtig geworden mit ehrt
mit dem gebrauch von erdöl der uns
völlig erlaubt hat erst kohle und öl die
produktion von menschlicher muskelkraft
abzukoppeln
das heißt es ist nicht nur menschlicher
arbeit das ist jetzt auch maschinen
arbeiten die sind viel schneller als
wären dadurch wurden wir für reiche viel
technologisch mächtiger und da wurde
dieser ansatz zum problem weil jetzt auf
einmal die konsequenzen von dem was wir
tun die verschmutzung der ozeane die
abholzung der regenwälder das
verschwinden des polareises radikalen
geworden sind davor war das noch nicht
so ein problem aber es war glaube ich
eine echte eine echte intellektuelle
revolution vor 3000 jahren als die
meisten schauen sie sich das nachbarland
griechenland an von palästina da
erlebten die menschen wie die
allermeisten zivilisationen in einem
gewebe göttlicher interessen
das heißt wenn sie in see stechen
wollten mussten sie pro seite und opfern
damit er ihre reise gnädig ansah und sie
wussten auch es gibt alle möglichen
wasser nymphen und es gibt dämonen und
es gibt furien und es gibt andere götter
und die wollen vielleicht nicht das was
poseidon will aber auf jeden fall jede
handlung die sie vollziehen
ist unmittelbar verknüpft mit allen
möglichen interessen von naturkräften
was ist poseidon spry die kraft des
meeres
das heißt die natur ist immer teilnehmer
der menschlichen geschichte
und dann kommt die hebräische bibel und
sagt nein diese erde die sagt euch
nichts die will nichts von euch dieses
territorium mit der könnt ihr tun was
ihr wollt ihr können sie und fügen
konzert messen ihr könnt sie verkaufen
ihr können sich anbohren
ihr müsst sogar aber die trockene erde
darin sieht und weil man kanalsysteme
legen muss aber ihr seid darüber erhaben
ihr seid nicht teil davon ihr steht
darauf mit euren füßen im staub mit
eurem kopf in der luft und dieses
weltverständnis ist wahnsinnig wird
mächtig geworden aber es wird jetzt zum
mühlstein um unseren hals ist die bibel
schuld am klimawandel und eine
zerstörung die das ist nur ein besonders
prägnanter moment ich meine auch die
römer haben sehr expansiv gelebt und
sehr extrahieren und gelebt das ist
nicht nur ein fehler des christentums
aber es wurde sicherlich auch durch das
christentum transportiert und es gibt
viele altphilologen die jetzt sagen ja
aber das ist nur eine fehl- übersetzung
das heißt eigentlich gar nicht macht
euch die erde untertan das heißt
eigentlich seid ein guter schäfer für
die erde ein guter hirte pflegt sie hier
aber das problem ist die hybrid das
hebräische original hat sich nicht
durchgesetzt mit all seinen
philologischen fragen sondern die
lateinische übersetzung und die
luther-bibel die deutsche übersetzung
und die sind ganz klar macht durch die
erde untertan
das heißt dieser ansatz der dann in der
aufklärung zur aufgeklärten natur
beherrschung wird zur wissenschaftlichen
technologischen natur beherrschung und
der dann in noch einem übersetzungs
schritt in der heutigen ökonomie
das wird das in einer ökonomischen
berechnung zumindest so wie man ökonomie
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert gedacht hat
da geht es um kapitalströme da geht es
um produkte da geht es um maschinen da
geht es um produktionsmethoden es geht
nie darum ob sie auch bei sauberen luft
und sauberes wasser haben oder ob die
biodiversität so gut ist dass dass sie
überhaupt dort leben können
das sind extremitäten die gehören der
rechnung nicht so bei und das ist
faszinierend also wir sind immer noch
draussen wir gehören immer noch nicht
dazu in unserem eigenen für dieses neue
naturverständnis dass sie in gewisser
weise fordern wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe bedeuten dass man zurückgeht zu
diesem mythologischen bild und diese
naturkräfte wieder ernst nimmt nein das
ist keine ideologie und es geht auch
nicht darum dass wir zurück auf die
bäume gehen wir brauchen die allerbesten
ingenieure und die allerbesten
wissenschaftlichen prozesse und
technologien um überhaupt noch was zu
schaffen
aber ich glaube es geht vielmehr darum
dass jede weltsicht ist im prinzip eine
art metapher wir können die welt nie so
sehen wie sie ist wir können sie immer
noch unsere kulturellen perspektive
heraus sehen und die damalige metapher
die hatte glaube ich einige wichtige
dinge verstanden nämlich die tatsache
dass wir immer verstrickt sind in die
welt dass wir dazugehören dass wir nicht
besonders wichtig sind längst nicht so
wichtig wie plankton oder ameisen zum
beispiel märchen sind weniger wichtig
aus planken natürlichen natürlich
plankton ist der anfang einer
gigantischen nahrungskette ohne ameisen
würde kaum verwesen stattfinden
empfehlen oder ohne pilze also menschen
sind nicht so wahnsinnig wichtig auf
diesem planeten menschen sind für
menschen wichtig die mythologien hatten
verstanden dass wir diese dass wir diese
verstrickte lebensweise innerhalb natur
haben
wenn wir das jetzt wenn wir mal die
götter beiseite lassen könnten und diese
fundamentale einsicht gebrauchen können
und das in wissenschaftlichem vokabular
neue ausdrücken können sowie das
menschen tun wie bruno latour zum
beispiel dann wird das auch einmal etwas
sehr interessantes grüner natur zum
beispiel der in diesem selbst selben
tempo
der französische soziologe und dann
eigentlich philosophie jetzt der gesagt
hat wir sollten eigentlich gar nicht
mehr daran denken dass wir auf der erde
leben wie gesagt füße im staub und kopf
in den
reinen höhe sondern wir leben in der
kritischen zone und die kritische zone
das ist diese seltsame winzige membran
von gas die zwischen den toten die
steine unter unseren füßen ist und der
ewigen lehre über unseren köpfen und nur
in diese membran können wir existieren
und in dieser membran gibt es unendlich
viele akteure die dinge tun und dinge
verändern von den ameisen bis zu den
höhen finden und von der
umweltgesetzgebung bis zum plankton und
jede diese aktion hat eine auswirkung
und in diesem in dieser kritischen zone
in diesen sensiblen membran müssen wir
uns irgendwie zurecht finden wenn wir
florieren wollen das finde ich eine
vision mit der ich mich sehr gut
anfreunden kann und das ist der alten
mythologischen visionen nicht so
wahnsinnig weit entfernt ohne auf hippie
den zurückzugreifen oder irgendwie new
age esoterische zu denken
aber wenn man sich überlegt was das für
die rechtsprechung für die moral
bedeuten könnte da gibt es ja vorschläge
zum beispiel in neuseeland da hat man
glaube ich versucht nicht nur dann
menschenrechte zu geben sondern auch
einem fluss hier zum beispiel oder ein
wald ich glaube das ist ein ganz
konsequente entwicklung wir erleben
jetzt und ich finde ich spannend weil
man da da wird dieser umbruch auf einmal
sichtbar
wir haben die menschenrechte gehabt die
reine erfindung der aufklärung sind
menschen haben keine rechte genauso
wenig wie hasen rechte haben kein tier
hat in der natur ein recht nicht zu
verhungern zum beispiel oder nicht von
einem anderen tier gefressen zu werden
aber wir sehen das auch bei anderen
tieren dass sie sich innerhalb einer
gruppe gegenseitig rechte geben wenn sie
ein wolf sind an einem wolfsrudel haben
sie sowohl rechte und pflichten
wenn sie also was zum beispiel waren sie
fressen dürfen wo sie in der hackordnung
stehen wo sie in der paarung ordnung
steht und so weiter das heißt aber auch
sie haben gewisse recht wir sind die
einzige thema die gesagt hat wir denen
diese rechte nicht nur auf mitglieder
unserer unmittelbaren gruppe aus sondern
auf alle die diese spezies angehören
theoretisch natürlich ist es eine schöne
fiktion wie während der flüchtlingsfrage
und da fängt diese dynamik an jetzt
wirklich interessant zu werden
in der flüchtlingsfrage haben wir zu
unserer aller scham erlebt und jetzt
nochmal der facebook ganz besonders
brutal
während wir alle das kleine heimatlose
kind gefeiert haben das in seiner krippe
lag sind die da im schlamm gesessen und
wir haben uns nicht um sie gekümmert
aber da erleben wir eine dramatische
begrenzung von menschenrechten alle
menschen haben menschenrecht aber wir
doch ein bisschen mehr wenn sie brauner
sind dann haben sie ihn schon ein
bisschen dann ist es eher theoretisch
und will wenn sie zu hause bleiben haben
sie volle menschenrechte genießen sie
die bitte dort das heißt das ist eine
dramatische zusammenziehung der mensch
würde ich da aber dann erleben wir eben
auch dass diese fiktion wenn man der
einmal als fiktion begreift und wenn man
einmal begreifen dass wir nicht
außerhalb der natur stehen
da muss man sagen okay wie es mit den
rechten von anderen primaten mit welchem
recht pärchen wird ihren tierfabriken 1
wie ist es mit dem recht eines
ökosystems weiterhin funktionieren zu
können wie es mit dem richten und noch
ungeborener generationen selber
ressourcen zum leben zu haben
also dann werden unsere ethischen und
moralischen beziehungen so anderen
teilen der natur völlig anders bei
tieren kann ich das gut nachvollziehen
man tiere leiden können und mit jeremy
bentham zum beispiel einen guten preis
zwischen philosophen kann man sagen das
ist das entscheidende kriterium um
jemanden rechte zuzusprechen
aber bei einer pflanze oder einem fluss
oder ein ökosystem
naja ich weiß nicht nur im fluss sondern
ist ein ganzes system aber zum zweiten
geht es ja einfach darum wie man wenn
man gute dinge durchsetzbar macht denn
ein recht ist ja wirklich nur infektion
wenn es nur herrn schiller gibt einen
boden darüber schreibt es wird erst
etwas handgreiflich ist wenn es auch
gesetze gibt und gerichte und polizei
die das durchsetzen dass man auch gegen
eine große macht seine seine rechte
argumentieren und durchsetzen können und
das ist nun mal die konstruktion die wir
in unserer gesellschaft gefunden haben
um das ohne blutvergießen zu tun
wir verteilen mecht macht das recht
durch gerichte und werde teil macht
durch politik mir hat mal ein
wunderbarer alter englischer parlaments
abgeordnete gesagt dass wichtige in
einer demokratie ist nicht wie wir
jemanden wählen sondern wie wir ihn
loswerden ohne blut zu vergießen das
fand ich wunderbar also dafür ist dafür
ist die wir haben herrn also methoden
gefunden wie wir gewisse ressourcen
verteilen auch nicht nur geld durch
steuern sondern zum beispiel auch recht
und macht und wenn wir sehen das ist
auch in unserem interesse ist aber dass
wir auch gar nicht mehr die trennung so
gut argumentieren können zwischen uns
und dem rest dann ist es glaube ich
nicht schwer zu argumentieren warum auch
einfluss daher nicht nur ein wasser
rinnsal ist sondern ein universum von
lebewesen die system ist zusammengehören
und natürlich steht immer am ende des
ganzen oder in beziehung damit der
mensch auch das heißt jedes recht für
einen fluss ist natürlich recht für
menschen frauen für zukünftige mensch
herr blum wenn ich ihnen zuhöre das ist
ein welt wird das glaube ich für viele
unsere zuhörerin zuschauerin
überraschend ist dieses dieses
naturverständnis dieses
selbstverständnis von uns menschen als
rein biologische wesen aber auch die
einsicht dass unsere lebensform unsere
art unser system wie wir jetzt
weitermachen dass das keine zukunft
haben gab es bei ihnen biografisch einen
moment wo sie das fest machen können wo
sie sagen da habe ich das eingesehen
dass wir erstens nur natur sind
unserer natur verhältnis radikal
verändern müssen aber auch dass die art
und weise wie wir leben produzieren
wirtschaften
weil ich keine zukunft hat es war kein
moment es war eigentlich mehr für mich
ein prozess ich habe vor sagen wir 15 20
jahren noch sehr wenig an solche dinge
gedacht war mit meinem kopf in ganz
anderen problemen
aber dann kamen die ersten dinge über
klimawandel und ich habe das genauso
wenig ernst genommen wie andere menschen
auch
aber es schien mir doch so wichtig dass
ich mich damit beschäftigt habe und wenn
man sich damit beschäftigt dass es keine
lustige angelegenheit dann alle studien
sagen es geht in die falsche richtung
und vielleicht eine katastrophale
richtung das schönste was man sich dann
seine tage sagen kann ist wie schön dass
wissenschaft in modellen denkt das heißt
wir kennen die reale zukunft noch nicht
wir wissen und nach diesem modell sieht
sie gar nicht gut aus aber es gibt schon
noch so kleine moment meine frau kommt
aus neuseeland und wir waren dort einmal
in einem in einer sternwarte die in
einer dunkelheit schutzzone liegt das
heißt da darf niemand nachts ein helles
licht aufdrehen und deswegen kann man da
die milchstraße mit dem bloßen auge
sehen und es ist ja dass allein schon es
sehr bewegend zu als kleines menschlein
zu sehen dass dieses gigantische riesige
ganze galaxie da also zu wissen es ist
eine der unbedeutend galaxien irgendwo
in einem winkel des universums ist wo
millionen von anderen noch da sind die
von dem wir keinerlei wissen haben und
zufällig war an diesem ort der wirklich
mitten in der pampa soir waren ganz
viele chinesen busweise und wir hörten
es ist einer der orte der von chinesen
am allermeisten besucht wird und wir
fanden das faszinierend und haben dann
einen der dortigen chinesischen
touristen angesprochen und er hat gesagt
ja er hätte schon immer helfer so
ungefähr um die 40 er hätte schon immer
von sternen gehört und er wollte sie
doch gerne auch einmal selbst sehen ja
und wenn man in china heute auf sagt
dann sieht man den sternenhimmel nicht
mehr und das ist sozusagen das ist dann
vielleicht ein anderes verhältnis zur
natur aber es zeigt auch wie die
alltäglich diese zerstörung inzwischen
für menschen geworden ist auch die
zerstörung oder die verarmung ihres
eigenen lebens interessant da sie von
ihnen stammt der satz jede gesellschaft
braucht eine art von transzendenz etwas
das über uns hinaus weiß sie haben den
sternenhimmel erwähnt das wäre eine form
ein religiöser glaube ist eine andere
form aber auch eine zukunftsvision wäre
etwas aber gefehlt und sagen sie heute
was wäre so eine transzendenz der
zukunft die sie unterschreiben könnten
ich glaube das müsste man auf zwei
ebenen und oder kann man auf zwei ebenen
argumentieren
zuerst mal kann man die zukunftsvision
ganz handgreiflich sehen also ich glaube
tatsächlich wir leben in gesellschaften
die nicht mehr hoffnung auf eine bessere
zukunft haben unsere beste hoffnung
politisch wenn sie unseren politischen
diskurs ansehen wenn sie an sehen
worüber wir diskutieren ist nicht zu
verlieren was wir bereits haben oder die
größte katastrophe zu verändern wir
glauben nicht mehr daran dass wir an
einem konstruktiven projekt gemeinsam
arbeiten in unseren gesellschaften
ich glaube dass turn doch sehr viele
menschen oft von der politik das denken
sich wenn das jetzt nur noch um hier
geht und um statuserhalt das ist das
interessiert mich nicht
und wenn wenn die liberale demokratie
bedeutet dass ich keine chance mehr in
diesem system dass ich mich nicht mehr
verbessern kann
in diesem system dann fühle ich mich
auch betrogen das kann ich gut verstehen
also ich glaube das ist eine eine
gesellschaft ohne rationale
zukunftshoffnung verrottet eigentlich
von innen und wird dann irgendwann zur
reifen frucht führt zb diktat worden
oder für autoritäre figuren wie könnte
so eine zukunft aussehen stellen sie
sich mal vor wir würden uns wirklich
dafür einsetzen
auch etwas dafür aufopfern böses wort
dass wir sagen wir wollen ein europa
bauen dass 2050 oder 20 100 ein besserer
ort ist als jetzt in europa wo wir wenn
wir kinder haben oder wenn wir kinder
treffen und sehen uns nicht vor denen
sie wissen wollen wo wir sagen können
wir haben es echt versucht wir haben
nicht versucht eine grüne infrastruktur
aufzubauen
unsere wirtschaft ist jetzt auf karbon 0
wir haben
alles getan was wir tun konnten um die
grundlagen unseres lebens zu entgiften
damit ihr auch noch leben könnten dieser
welt ich glaube das wären wichtig ist
und das wäre ein wertvolles projekt das
andere und das wie gesagt das ist dass
es ganz handgreiflich bucht
durchbuchstabiert anhand von steuern und
wirtschaftspraxis und treibstoffen etc
das andere ist ein viel größeres projekt
viel interessanter ist das andere ist zu
sagen wir stehen eigentlich am ende von
3000 jahren kulturgeschichte und das ist
die zeit wo sich der mensch die erde
untertan macht wo er der boss ist die
zeit der unterwerfung der extraktion der
der herrschaft der nominierung der
eroberung wir lernen jetzt dass die
natur eigentlich ganz anders
funktioniert wir lernen jetzt dass bäume
überhaupt nur wachsen können weil sie
mit pilzen zusammenarbeiten und dass die
pilze untereinander kommunizieren und
untereinander nährstoffe austauschen und
das ist ein web gibt was das was die
ganze welt umspannt an kommunikation
zwischen pflanzen und pilzen und anderen
organismen das all dieser organismen nur
entstehen können nur entstehen und
bestehen können weil sie mit anderen
organismen zusammenarbeiten weil sie
teil von einem größeren ganzen sind zu
dem sie ihren beitrag leisten aus dem
sie etwas ziehen aber sie können weil
sie sind gar nicht in diese situation
denkbar
wie wäre es wenn wir uns nach der logik
verstehen von einer logik der nomination
hin zu einer logik der kollaboration
nicht weil wir plötzlich bessere
menschen geworden sind sondern weil wir
begriffen haben die natur funktioniert
so und wenn wir überleben wollen müssen
wir auch so funktionieren lernen das
würde auch das menschen verständnis
glaube ich das menschenbild radikal
ändern es würde übrigens auch unsere
politik ändern
auch in der politik wäre es ein
erstaunlicher unterschied weg gingen von
einer logik der nomination sondern logik
der kooperation würden sie sagen dieses
umdenken
dieses dieser bewusstseinswandel ist die
voraussetzung für diese grüne revolution
die berühmte henne und ei frage das eine
geht nicht ohne das andere
wir können nicht da sitzen und däumchen
drehen und warten bis alle menschen
spirituell erleuchtet sind und in einer
besseren welt zu leben
wir müssen jetzt etwas tun und jetzt
handgreifliche dinge tun
ich meine wir können noch nicht nur neue
steuern einführen und dann schauen dass
die welt besser wird also es muss ganz
intensiv glaube ich an beidem gearbeitet
ich meine die klimabewegung forderte
dass die fordert dass es viel schneller
geht und viele radikaler geht als die
politik ist derzeit macht da ist vom
klima notstand auch die rede wie stehen
sie zu dieser bewegung zu diesen
begriffen
ich finde das erstaunlich und enorm
positiv weil das auch tatsächlich der
moment ist ich habe ihnen vorhin gesagt
dass wir das im 17 jahrhundert man
beobachten kann wie ein neuer arten des
wissens und neue arten sich die welt zu
erzählen auftauchen damals magie in der
chemie hinzu und wir haben heute
freitags verführer und wir haben heute
gegen die verschwörungstheorie und sie
sehen auch wir heute neue arten von
wissen versuchen die welt neu zu
erklären wie er so wieder so ein
paradigma zerbricht und neue sachen
daran stoßen
das ist wichtig und spannend es ist aber
auch sehr gefährlich denn in so einer
situation wo so viele neue geschichten
und wissen daten ausprobiert werden
gewinnt nicht immer die netteste hitler
und stalin hatten sehr faszinierende
geschichten zu erzählen am anfang ihrer
karriere sonst hätten sie es nicht so
weit geschafft
also ich glaube dass diese das dass
diese dinge wie viel es verfügt ja
wahnsinnig wichtig sind weil sie
natürlich auch weil es junge menschen
sind und weil das einen gewissen
ethischen ethisches gefühl mit mit sich
bringt deswegen ist natürlich auch die
resistenz gegen sie besonders stark
meistens von männern eines gewissen
alters
er lief in was will uns dieses junge
mädchen da etwas aufoktroyieren aber es
ist völlig klar wir leben in einem klima
notstand und es ist völlig klar das ist
nicht etwas was irgend wann mal
passieren wird das ist etwas was bereits
jetzt passiert
was unabsehbare konsequenzen hat und
woran wir gemessen werden werden wie
sehr wir haben mich sehr mich vorhin
gefragt wie wird das jahr 2020 in der
geschichte gesehen werden können sie
sich vorstellen wie unsere generation in
der geschichte gesehen wird die
verschwenderische generation der
menschheitsgeschichte die sich weigert
etwas daran zu tun weil ich denke das
stand ja jemand anderes tun
die frage stellt sich für mich einfach
mit welchen mitteln wir jetzt diese
notbremse ziehen wenn sich herr notstand
ist und wie viel demokratie wie viel
freiheit man opfern darf und meine
kollegin barbara bleisch hat vor kurzem
mit dem co vorsitzenden der grünen in
deutschland gesprochen mit der robert
habeck
und der sieht ja auch eine gewisse
gefahr was die radikale klimabewegung
angeht wir hören mal kurz zu
wir schützen am ende wenn wir das klima
schützen die offene gesellschaft vor
krieg verlust von lebensräumen von
ernährungs con tagen von wasser und so
weiter wir schützen die offene
gesellschaft und versuchen zu verhindern
in eine nicht steuerbare dystopische
totalitäre katastrophale welt ab zu
bleiben da ein bisschen sonne george
orwell welt wird die kontinente
miteinander im krieg bestehen wenn wir
aber die offene freie gesellschaft
schützen
dann macht es keinen sinn die kaputt zu
machen um das klima zu schützen das dann
haben wir gleich verloren wir mit dem
hintern eingerissen war mit den händen
verteidigen wollen was wiegt mehr die
grundrechte demokratie freiheit auf der
einen seite oder die zukunft das wohl
zukünftiger generationen
das ist glaube ich in jedem fall eine
abwägungsfrage wir kennen noch diese
zukünftige generation nicht wir haben
die weisheit nicht mit löffeln gefressen
wir haben viel erreicht in unseren
gesellschaften
ich würde nicht in einer anderen
gesellschaft leben wollen was dinge wie
menschenrechte minderheitenrechte und
übrigens auch zum beispiel zahnmedizin
betrifft also aber wie das abzuwägen ist
ich glaube dass das kann man mit
größeren steuerungsmechanismen
versuchen aber letztendlich muss ist
eine frage des willens von menschen
seien das kann man menschen nicht
diktieren
letztendlich sie haben gefragt was kann
man tun
ehrlich gesagt ich will hoffen dass dies
jetzt nicht nur eine stunde fernsehen
ist sondern dass menschen auch zuhören
und weggehen und ein bisschen nachdenken
und vielleicht denken na ja damen sind
nicht recht gehabt aber das finde ich
eigentlich ganz interessant und mit
anderen ins gespräch kommen und so kann
eine gesellschaft anfangen sich zu ende
er habe es bei ihm habe ich auch gelesen
dass kluge selbstbeschränkung ein unsinn
ist dass wir darauf nicht setzen sollten
aber das ist zumindest sehr gefährlich
ist in der jetzigen situation sondern
dass es dass es mehr braucht und sie
schildern da in ihrem sehr lesenswerten
buch das 2017 erschienen ist was auf dem
spiel steht und spoiler es steht alles
auf dem spiel
jetzt kann man sagen machen sie ein
gedankenexperiment sehr interessantes
und zwar denken wir uns das eines nachts
eine zahn fühlen menschen die
schreckliche zukunft offenbaren wird wie
die welt in 50 100 jahren aussehen wird
die welt menschen werden nicht klüger
werden nicht moralisch besser sondern
einfach besser informiert über die
zukunft die wachen auf und dann schauen
sie was aus passiert was passiert da was
naja ich hab ich spinne das spektiv
natürlich etwas aus und sagt nach der
ersten selbstmordwelle kommen an die
religiösen propheten aber aber
irgendwann kommt dann eben auch die
einsicht unter diesen umständen müssen
wir gewisse dinge tun und diese einsicht
die ist die es uns durch ko wieder ein
bisschen näher gerückt da war wird
sicherlich etwas gutes denn die
klimaveränderung gut wir leben alle
inzwischen in wintern ohne winter und im
sommer ist es wärmer aber für die leute
im reichen europa sind das nicht so
wahnsinnig unangenehme nebeneffekte im
garten gedeiht jetzt dies besser als das
und die vogelpopulation hat sich etwas
verändert ist übrigens auch viel weniger
geworden
dahinter stehen an solche kleinen zahlen
wie das 60 prozent aller insekten
verschwunden sind aus europa wegen
industrie war landwirt intensiver
landwirtschaft
festreden etc also noch eine ökologische
katastrophe ersten ausmaßes den mann in
seinem garten auch mit sehen kann
aber diese dinge haben die menschen
nicht wirklich existenziell berührt und
wir lernen nicht durch argumente wir
lernen nur durch erfahrungen kommt ist
das erste mal dass wir alle dazu
gezwungen wurden zu hause zu bleiben
dass wir alle dazu gezwungen wurden
unser leben einzuschränken und zu
verändern weil hier eine
naturkatastrophe stattfindet und weil
wir begreifen wir sind nicht außerhalb
dieser katastrophe sondern wir sind ein
kleiner teil davon
dieser blöde kleine virus der so
primitiv ist wie nur irgend eine
lebensform eigentlich so primitiv das
wissenschaftlich noch nicht mal wirklich
für leben halten
der hat die progressivsten größten
wirtschaftsräume der welt lahmgelegt
innerhalb von kürzester zeit
ich kann nur hoffen dass das eine dass
das auch schon einen effekt hat dass das
dass menschen einfach begreifen fühlen
das ist anders ich stehe da nicht
draußen was da passiert ist betrifft
mich direkt und man muss auch begreifen
es gibt keine lokalen probleme mehr
bevor der korona krise und das war eine
zahl ich habe die drei mal nach
recherchiert weil ich dachte es kann ja
nicht wahr sein
vor der korona krise verschwand der
regenwald auf der welt in einer
geschwindigkeit von 30 fußballfeldern
pro minute
ich sag das nochmal 30 fußballfelder pro
minute von regenwald das hat sich
während corona noch verstärkt
beschleunigt gerade in brasilien weil
die leute abgelenkt waren und was mit
dem brasilianischen regenwald passiert
ist wichtig für die schweiz
denn es ist wichtig für das klima in der
schweiz was mit dem markt ist passiert
ist wichtig für die schweiz und für
andere länder
das heißt es gibt auch keine lokalen
probleme mehr und sobald wir anfangen
das am eigenen leib zu erfahren
und das nicht von irgendwelchen
irritierenden klugen leuten in irgend
einer fernsehshow erzählt zu bekommen
sondern das wirklich zu
dann beginnt die chance dass ich etwas
verändern kann aber gleichzeitig gibt es
die gegenbewegung gegen die
globalisierung den nationalismus den
populismus die abschottung kontrolle
zurückzubekommen take control und so
weiter und diese tendenz ist glaube ich
nicht zu unterschätzen heute und das
sagen sie ja ist eine der großen
gefahren nämlich die die zerstörung der
liberalen demokratien und das nennen sie
den autoritären traum
wie gefährlich ist der mächtigste der
ist sehr wichtig und er ist sehr
gefährlich
und natürlich wir tendieren alle dazu
meinungen zu haben nicht weil sie wie
sie gut durchdacht und durch gut durch
argumentiert haben sondern weil sie sich
gut anfühlen
warum halten sich 80 prozent der
menschen für überdurchschnittlich gute
alte fahrer 30
es ist immerhin es gibt dafür
offensichtlich keinen empirischen beweis
aber es fühlt sich gut an
so haben wir auch unsere politischen
überzeugung wir haben die weise sich gut
anfühlen sehr oft und das zu ändern das
ist es ist schwerer das ist eine
herausforderung aber dass das ist glaube
ich auch möglich über das problem ist
das natürlich take control ist ein
absurder satz in einer welt in der ein
moderner staat nicht einmal dem wert
seiner währung kontrolliert nicht
kontrolliert was mit eisernen
pensionsfonds passiert nein seine eigene
steuer basis nicht mehr kontrolliert
weil große firmen einfach abwandern und
woanders hingehen wo die steuern besser
sind seine eigene
verteidigungspolitischen nicht
kontrolliert wenn es um terrorismus gibt
globale finanzströme tz 13
kein land ist mehr souverän in diesem
sinn aber es klingt toll
wir nehmen jetzt kontrolle zurück wir
sind jetzt wieder der chef von natürlich
ist das nicht so in großbritannien waren
trans produziert das in europa verkaufen
für den muss es europäische standards
beachten da hat es keine kontrolle
darüber
wenn es in der eu geblieben wäre hätte
es ein mitspracherecht gehabt wer diese
regeln macht und wie diese regeln
diese kontrolle hat es jetzt aus der
hand gegeben also es geht nicht darum
was war es geht sich darum es geht darum
was sich gut anfühlt wenn jemand kommt
und den leuten etwas sagt was ich gut
genug anfühlt dieser klimawandel gibt es
gar nicht oder es gibt immer
klimawandels ist alles gar nicht so
das wird euch nur eingeredet damit man
euch angst macht und man will euch chips
einpflanzen man will ich kontrollieren
diese welt ist so unübersichtlich
geworden und so schwierig zu verstehen
geworden dass das einem auf einmal
einfaches muster gibt wie man die welt
verstehen kann und das ist vielen
menschen mehr wert als die fakten
ja aber diese das was sich gut anfühlt
ist ja für viele heute die vergangenheit
also weil sie so viele ängste haben
wirtschaftliche abstiegsängste
kulturelle verlustängste alle diese
dystopischen szenarien der zukunft die
natürlich auch klimawissenschaftler dann
zeichnen
das weckt die sehnsucht diese
nostalgische sehnsucht zurück nach einer
vergangenheit die es nie gegeben hat
diese übergeben hat würden sie sagen
aber trotzdem glaube ich wenn ich sie
ernst nehmen und wenn sie sagen
argumente bringen die menschen nicht zur
veränderung verändern uns überhaupt
nicht sondern es sind erfahrungen es
sind traumata und so weiter dann
brauchen wir doch eine gegen erzählung
oder immobilien schock an historischer
schock so wie man pandas oder eine
positive zukunftsvision die chance genau
wir brauchen beides der schock kommt
wir sind wir haben schon jetzt schon die
ersten schockwellen erlebt aber der
schock den werden wir schon bekommen
die große frage ist was tun wir mit
diesem schock ziehen wir uns zurück in
diktaturen und sagen wir das problem
sind die braun heutigen die rothaarigen
die brillenträger wer auch immer gerade
dann zur verfügung steht
die juden wie sie jetzt auch in vielen
verschwörungstheorien sind diese alten
alten antisemitischen theorien wieder
aufwärmen oder schaffen wir es
tatsächlich dem eine neue geschichte
entgegenzusetzen eine geschichte der
hoffnung die nur so aussehen kann dass
wir unseren platz in diesem immensen
system finden das wir noch nicht vor
und versuchen es nicht mehr aufweisen zu
ändern
die konnte eine kaskade von konsequenzen
los treten die uns vielleicht mit unter
sich begraben
das könnten ehrlich gesagt bessere
gesellschaften werden das könnten
weniger kompetitive kompetitive aber
nicht weniger offene gesellschaft werden
es ist schon richtig was robert habe
gesagt wir müssen auch die offenen
gesellschaft verteidigen und die offene
gesellschaft und hier wird kompliziert
wenn ein freund von mir hat mal gesagt
habe philosophie ist dass man hier mal
da und ein historiker ist immer jemand
der aufsteht und sagt es ist ein
bisschen komplizierter damit kann ich
nicht gut denn die hier wird's
kompliziert denn eine ein demokratisches
ein demokratisches gemeinwesen kostet
geld
sie müssen im parlament haben sie müssen
gericht ein gerichtssystem haben sie
brauchen polizei um diese sache noch
durchzusetzen etc etc
dieses geld kommt was kommt nur zustande
wenn es eine wirtschaft gibt die gut
funktioniert und die eben nicht nur von
von kohl und kartoffeln lebt sondern die
auch performativ ist und konkurrenzfähig
ist
wenn diese wirtschaft so viele rohstoffe
verbraucht dass sie unsere
lebensgrundlage untergräbt sind all
diese errungenschaft dafür nichts wenn
wir es aber schaffen diese wirtschaft so
umzubauen dass sie das trotzdem noch
schafft
das wäre dass sie ist das möglich ich
glaube das werden wir beide erleben
da kann ich es gibt immer so viele
faktoren in solchen historischen
entwicklung in vielen seiner biografie
im nachhinein es ist ganz klar im
nachhinein sieht man auch wie viel
unglaubliche zufälle im eigenen leben
eine rolle gespielt haben aber man kann
gewisse kausalitäten sehen jetzt in die
zukunft hinein zu sagen aber ich glaube
es ist völlig klar
die erzählung der globalen nominierung
die erzählung des unendlichen wachstums
die erzählung des menschen als herrn
erschöpfung die ist kaputt die ist
vorbei
wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit dem eine
andere empfehlung erzählen
entgegenzusetzen die einerseits besser
harmoniert mit dem was wir inzwischen
von der natur begriffen haben wie sie
funktioniert nicht nach den ideen der
alten griechen oder der bibel oder der
renaissance sondern nach den ideen
wesentlich modernere erkenntnisse und
wir könnten tatsächlich sehen ob wir
humanere gesellschaften konstruieren
können daraus die größte gefahr ist ja
immer dass man denkt so wie wir jetzt
leben ist normal und deswegen notwendig
nein so wie wir jetzt leben ist erstens
überhaupt nicht normal ist eine absolute
ausnahme in der menschheitsgeschichte
es ist auch gar nicht notwendig und ist
auch vielleicht auch gar nicht gut das
heißt es wäre doch eigentlich aufregend
wenn man sagen könnte wenn wenn wir
tatsächlich ganz andere wesen sind warum
was haben sie in der kurve krise
vermisst
ich nehme mal an wie zum beispiel auch
ich menschen berühren zu können mit
menschen von menschen umgeben zu sein
als rationaler mensch warum interessiert
sie das überhaupt
weil sie das als primat brauchen weil
ich das als affe brauche die körperliche
berührung mit anderen weil wir nicht
dafür gebaut sind rationale bedürfnisse
zu erfüllen und im ökonomischen
wettbewerb mit anderen individuen zu
bestehen das sind wir nicht
das ist eine der seine völlig contra
faktische eigentlich theologische vision
von menschen wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit uns unseren platz in der
natur mehr anzunähern und diesen platz
kreativer zu gestalten das ist
eigentlich ein aufregender moment eher
bloggen wir sind fast am ende des
gesprächs mich würde interessieren
persönlich was machen sie wenn diese
zukunftsvisionen angst einjagen und der
pessimismus überhandnimmt ist eine gute
frage
ich habe in meinen büchern das war nicht
absicht sondern das ist so passiert gibt
so ein bisschen wechsel zwischen den
beiden büchern zum beispiel liegt nicht
nur das über des 17ten jahrhundert
sondern auch ein buch über die geige die
ich besitze und spiele was für mich eine
reise war in eine vergangenheit
auch eine persönliche vergangenheit die
einmal nichts mit den ort der welt aber
das ist und wohnt im baur ihrer geige
nachgegeben und der biografie ich habe
die biografie eines unbekannten menschen
im 17 jahrhundert geschrieben
ich habe jetzt gerade im ersten locker
an einen historischen roman geschrieben
wenn mörder im 17 jahrhundert der auch
nichts mit klima zu tun hat also ich
versuche mich schon auch eine flucht in
die vergangenheit in einer gewissen
weise ja man braucht das also ich meine
in wien wo ich lebe da hat man dieses
wunderbare rezeptfrei ein weib und
gesang
das funktioniert für mich meistens sehr
gut und das sind auch tatsächlich dinge
also diese diese bestätigung positive
dinge durch zuwendung durch kultur durch
freundschaft das ist so wichtig gerade
wenn am horizont eine katastrophe steht
die die meisten menschen gar nicht
wahrhaben wollen klar als fürchterlich
ist sich das einzugestehen
weil es fürchterlich ist sich zu denken
um gottes willen ich hab doch kinder
was sollte das denen werden aber es ist
an der zeit dass wir uns diese fragen
stellen aber es ist auch an der zeit
dass wir vielleicht begreifen
unser normales nicht das normal und
unsere fantasie die wir mit so viel
hingabe den kindern austreiben
die ist vielleicht an rohstoff der viel
wichtiger ist als erdöl um aus diesem
problem uns irgendwie zu befreien
schön gesagt die fand dass ich aus
rohstoff für die zukunft einerseits
diese zukunftsvision
und wenn es mal ganz schlimm wird ein
bisschen wein und geige spielt das ist
doch schön
das ist ein gangbarer philipp blom 4 und
herzlichen dank für dieses
zukunftsweisende gespräch ich danke für
die einladung
ja auch ihnen danke fürs mitdenken
nächste woche legt sich meine kollegin
barbara bleisch auf die couch und fragt
welche philosophie eigentlich hinter
sigmund freuds psychoanalyse steckt zu
gast ist der psychoanalytiker und
satiriker peter schneider
kommende woche findet auch das zürcher
philosophie festivals statt thema der
diesjährigen ausgabe ist die lust sie
können alle veranstaltungen von 14 bis
januar online mitverfolgen und zwar
gratis
auf der webseite des festivals am
donnerstagabend geht es los mit einem
vortrags- und carolin jetzt gleich gehts
weiter mit seinem preisgekrönten film
über die knapp 80 jährige benedettini
topmodel während der 60er jahre musik
von andy warhol spät der radikale
feministin und professorin für
modedesign
das klingt vielversprechend bleiben sie
also dran und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]